début d'émission de Gérard votre frère
les journalistes politiques à France 2
vous en êtes fier je trouve qu'il a fait
une
belle d'abord il a fait des études
remarquables il m'a toujours bluffé
parce que
j'ai toujours vu s'amuser
ce qui prouve qu'il était très très bien
organisé c'était à l'époque où je
sortais pas mal et lui sortait aussi
beaucoup je le croisais dans les dans
les boîtes il y avait ces groupes de
copains et moi le mien évidemment
mais je sais pas comment il a réussi à
passer à voir tous ces diplômes et tout
ça en s'amusant autant et
puis après non il a il a fait vraiment
une belle carrière puis fait bien son
métier
je dirais déontologiquement et puis en
même temps il a ce côté qu'on a tous
dans la famille qui nous a été légué je
crois par notre Père qui est une forme
de pain forme une
honnêteté intellectuelle quelqu'un de
très pudique quelqu'un de très secret
aussi assez réservé il accepte une
manière très exceptionnelle et bien de
nous dire deux ou trois choses vous
concernant
et bien salut Julien juste deux trois
petites choses d'abord une question
après la grande maison à la campagne le
cheval la voile quelle sera ta prochaine
passion
exclusive et dévorante pour qu'on puisse
d'ores et déjà s'y préparer ensuite un
démenti pas pour toi mais pour tous ceux
qui me posent la question je suis plus
jeune que toi alors je sais que tu as
gardé toujours ton allure d'éternel
adolescent mais après tout moi je fais
pas si vieux que ça ensuite un démenti
ne t'inquiète pas tu peux boire du vin
blanc surtout si c'est du Saumur ça ne
fait pas mal entendu la preuve je cours
toutes les semaines enfin peut-être un
conseil puisque tu es ton meilleur
conseiller littéraire donne-moi un ou
deux livres à lire cet été voilà je te
rappelle à part ça que tu ne m'as
toujours pas envoyé ton dernier CD je ne
te parle pas de la carabine à flèche que
tu m'aies volé quand j'avais 11 ans ça
c'est tout oublié allez salut à bientôt
mais on va lui l'envoyer
le vin blanc j'en bois
je suis comme tout le monde je prends
des caisses de temps en temps sauf que
ça se voit pas ça se voit moins que pour
d'autres gens donc les gens croient
toujours que sobre comme un chameau mais
c'est pas toujours vrai c'est pour ça
quand je vous dis à sciatique tout à
l'heure ça me faisait rigoler mais
simplement je le fais pas tous les jours
bon et puis le vin blanc et pardon vous
êtes un véritable pas vraiment et sur le
vin blanc de Saumur il a complètement
raison il dit ça parce qu'il en fait un
peu lui il a il a des vignes familiales
mais
c'est vrai que j'ai gardé même si je me
suis mis au vin assez tard
nous avons gardé ça de notre éducation
aussi c'est de loin le vin blanc que je
préfère aussi et puis
évidemment pour les lectures j'ai lu un
petit livre récemment
d'une d'un auteur italien qui s'appelle
Loretta loi loi
qui s'appelle madame della Seta et juive
elle aussi et qui est sur le
sur la façon dont les Juifs ont été
traités
en Italie
peut-être pas comment les autres
personnes réagissent mais peut-être
parce que c'est l'Italie je me suis
toujours dit moi que j'ai toujours pensé
que ça avait été plus doux qu'ailleurs
mais pas du tout c'était aussi terrible
c'est exactement comme en Allemagne et
malheureusement comme en France donc
c'est un petit livre que vraiment
formidable
[Musique]